Hey everyone! It's Friday and you know what that means we got to get down. And how are we going to get down? We're going to get down on the short and long run equilibrium of the competitive firm. Let's go ahead and jump into it. Let's start by looking at the firm and market demand curves. Here we have the market first and we can see that the supply and demand intersect at a price of P1 and quantity Q1. And since the competitive firm is a price-taker they are going to have their price be P1. And we do recall that their demand curve is there marginal revenue curve at that price level. Now we're going to introduce the long run marginal cost curve and where that intersects the marginal revenue curve at quantity q1--and the little Q means that we're dealing with firm quantity that is our profit maximizing
or loss-minimizing output. If we bring in the long-run average total cost curve you can see that all of those curves intersect one another at quantity Q1. This means we are in a long-run equilibrium for the firm. Now let's say something happens. In this case the demand curve shifts from D1 to D2 and this is going to cause a higher price level to P2 and higher market output level to Q2.
What does that mean? That means that the firm now gets to produce at a higher price level and the firms inside of the current market are going to be producing more. So these firms produce q2 units each and we multiply that by all the firms and we have the big quantity Q2 on the right-hand side of that graph. This now also means that there's going to be a short run change and these firms are going to be earning a short-run economic profit.
We see that by this green box here. You'll notice that this does represent an economic profit because the price is above the average total cost curve. So these firms in the short run do earn profits and that is going to cause potential entrants to want to come into this market. So what's going to happen is that supply curve is going to shift to S2. This means that the market price goes from P2 back to P1.
All right this gives us an increase in output
of Q3. And where does that increase output come from? From the fact that the new firms coming into the market add on to the existing quantity. This drops right back down the P1 and we restore the long-run equilibrium. And you'll notice that the quantity for the original firm goes from q2 to q1, and that's because they no longer want to produce beyond their profit maximizing or lost minimizing output.
If we move to a change where it's going to be negative--so let's go in reverse this time--we again start with our equilibrium price P1 and Q1 for  our quantity. And the same thing for the firm.
And we're going to get our long run equilibrium condition like what we previously saw.
And then we're going to have a decrease in demand.  Some market condition caused the demand for this product or service to fall.
And when that happens the new price and equilibrium quantity are P2 and Q2. And this causes the competitive firm to go from a price of P1 up to a price of P2.
And notice what happens. They're now going to continue to produce where their marginal cost equals their marginal revenue, but they're going to be producing less.
And, in fact, this is going to cause an economic loss as shaded by the red area. And the reason, again, is because the price they're charging is less than average cost of producing that good. So we have a new short run condition where these firms are earning an economic loss.
What does that mean? That means that some firms cannot continue to stay inside of this market, so they are going to leave that market as denoted by the shift in the supply curve. This causes the supply curve to shift back to the left and this raises the market price back to P1. And this causes the overall level of output to fall to Q3 because there are no longer as many firms in this market.
And the firms who do remain in the market they go back to their original output level. So that is an increase and a decrease in demand causing changes in the long run. We'll actually have a look at one with some numbers. We're going to have an increase in demand so this is going to look a lot like what you saw in the first part and we're going to give the product price to be $10 in our total output level is 10,000.
And when you find the equilibrium conditions we see that each firm is producing 100 units of output. This means that there are 100 firms in this market. If we multiply the output by 100 we get the 10,000 total units of output being produced. Now let's make sure we are in long-run equilibrium. We are. And now let's disturb by having demand increase for some reason. Our new market price is $15 and we sell 12,000 units of this good. This causes us to have an increase in the price for the firm--they are price-takers--and a new equilibrium output level of 120 for each firm.
Let's look at the profit per unit of output so we subtract 15 - 11 and that gives us $4 per unit of output if we multiply that by 120 that is going to be the total amount of profit that we have for these firms. Now what happens? Potential entrants see this profit and then they come into the market and shift the supply curve to the right.
This is going to cause the price to fall from 15 to $10.
And our total output is going to is going to increase to 14,000 because those new entrants are coming into the market what ends up happening once that all occurs the price gets driven back down to $10 and our firms who were originally in the markets are now going back to their original level of output of 100. And that is all we have to do to figure out the short-run and long-run equilibrium changes with changing our demand and our supply curve.
Hope you enjoy it and I'll catch you in our next one.